>>Student: If you invest in us,
we're asking for $25,000
with 16 percent equity.
>>Advisor: I'm going to propose that you
sell your baskets for maybe like $40,
and I'm prepared to give you 50,000.
>>Chae: The whole focus of Personalized
Learning is the students see the
relevance of what it
is that they're doing.
And so the outcome is
students are engaged.
They're enjoying the learning process.
They're working collaboratively
with others.
They're able to share what
it is that they've learned.
And have their own successes.
>>Chae: Here at Nashville Big
Picture High School, we offer rigor,
we offer relevance, we offer
relationships, and all of it is centered
around students and their
Personalized Learning.
>>Gary: Who would be the ideal
target for somebody who's trying
to recruit for a group like this.
>>Student: Really, it's just
anyone who has like a gap
in their life that they need to fill.
>>Gary: Oh, man, that's
a killer statement.
>>Gary: I think the essence of
Personalized Learning is understanding
where the students is and
where they want to go.
We use a lot of project work in class.
And with the project work, I try
to give them Voice and Choice.
Give them a menu of options
that they can research.
Also a menu of options that they
can choose to show learning.
>>Gary: The last group that we'll hear
from today will be Naomi,
Brianna and Nicole.
And they are going to inform us
on what exactly the Black Lives
Movement is and what it's about.
>>Nicole: In Mr. Gary's class, we have
U.S. History, and what we do is learn
about different things that
is going on in the world,
either from the past, or
what's going on today.
>>Nicole: Eric Garner, he died,
he was standing out after eight.
New York police officer
put him in a chokehold,
and his last words were,
"I can't breathe."
>>Nicole: So my project
was Black Lives Matter,
and I chose that because I'm
kind of passionate about that.
I'm passionate about Black Rights.
>>Student: Black Lives
Matter was created in 2012
after Trevon Martin's murder.
>>Gary: It puts them in the role of
being the expert, and they're able
to share with students about
something that they've researched,
and it gives them a sense of confidence,
because they have that role in front
of the room, and they're
sharing that information.
>>Gary: You guys, good job!
We'll pick up on Friday morning.
>>Chae: When it comes to
personalizing our learning,
we do have some commonality, so
that when we do have projects,
we also have to look at
content and what standards are.
But student voice is key.
So it's students-centered, because a lot
of the ways of, "How did you learn it?"
some of that comes from
the students' voice.
>>Derick: And right now I want
to go around with everybody
and talk to you about your product.
See where you are.
I'm going to ask you about your
equations that we worked on last class.
The better you feel about your
product, the better it will be.
>>Derick: We have started a
project called Shark Tank,
it's just like the TV show.
>>Derick: You'll present your product,
we'll give you feedback and say,
"I'm gonna invest in your company," or,
"I'm not going to invest
in your company."
>>Derick: What I wanted to do
was give the students opportunity
to create their own business.
It could be real, it could be imaginary,
but to create a business
that they have a product.
>>Student: It's going
to be like solar panels
on a iPhone case that
charges up the phone.
>>Derick: What is your
product going to sell for?
>>Student: Okay, they're going
to sell for $4.99 plus tax.
>>Derick: $4.99?
>>Student: Mm hm, plus tax.
And it's going to come up to
five dollars and nine cents.
>>Derick: So that's all
you need for the campaign
to get started, to get people to buy it.
>>Dan: It had to have a marketing
piece, they had to make a promo,
print a logo that promotes your brand.
You could have a jingle, and if you
have a jingle you can just sing it,
or you know, or like
[Dan and Student sing].
>>Dan: How do you like to learn math?
What are you good at?
Do you like music?
Let's sing a song about
quadratic functions.
You like to draw?
Let's draw a graph, and
let's paint a picture.
We're covering the same
standards, but it looks different.
>>Dan: This a video?
>>Chris: Part of the product.
>>Dan: Oh, that's right,
you got the cranium.
>>Chris: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>>Chris: Personalized education, it's
really the dame thing, but you get more
of what you're interested
in, so that's good,
because you like also get an
insight to what you want to do.
>>Student: Hello, everyone.
This is Impulse Products.
And we would like to
present Arctic Impulse.
>>Derick: They did all this research,
they got in groups of three or four,
and then presented their project.
>>Student: This is how we created,
and this is where we usually
distribute across the U.S.
>>Derick: Me and my Advisors, we were
the Sharks, we were sitting on the side.
At the end of the project, they would
throw out some investment numbers,
just like Shark Tank, they
give a dollar amount, usually,
and they give an equity amount.
>>Student: Our investment,
we were going to ask
for ten percent of equity for $100,000.
>>Derick: I'll give you $75,000
cash, but I want 17 percent equity.
>>Gary: I'm going to give you $100,00
for 20 percent equity in the company.
[laughter] Money talks.
I need to know right now, though.
I need to know either
you're in or you're not.
>>Class: Seven, six, five--
>>Student: Mr. Derick.
>>Derick: Yeah!
Whoo! [clapping]
>>Derick: I never seen these kids
get excited about a math project.
Everybody got involved!
Even the kids that were
not good in math.
They were getting involved.
They were doing quadratic functions.
They were doing all these things.
I would be silly, as a teacher,
not to give them that opportunity
to be creative and get
excited about a math project.
>>Student: I learned how to market my
business, and make new investments.
>>Chae: When you're able to
make it relevant to a student,
it helps them to want to
do it, and not just do it
because that's what's expected.
Student voice is key.
Hear it, learn it, ask for it.
What is it that will help you do better.
How can we help you improve?
What do you need from us?
>>Gary: I'm in for 50,000,
and just to make it sweet,
let's keep it at 15 percent.
[applause]
>>Derick: All right!
I feel ya!